bene di generazioni di vj oggi siamo
parlati su six il set
vuoi che mi può spiegare perché c'è una
pizza sul tetto hanno forse visto che mi
arriva la pinza ogni volta che gioca sta
roba o cose ma tra i ragazzi se clicco
soltanto salvai qualcosa succede di
preciso facciamo sempre sar bomba perché
tanto siamo pro della madonna se questa
roba che non ho capito c'è se io ho
sempre cliccato apocalypse ma questo non
ho mai cliccato day one a sono soltanto
io e mia figlia ma come non c'è un cazzo
e sono solo io e mia figlia fantastico
che che senso apcom e come potrei mai
vivere con questa impossibile d'accordo
ragazzi ultimo test in generale provare
a sopravvivere solo con me e mia figlia
cosa mai vista prove mary jane sembra
posto nessun altro problema perfetto da
ragazzi mandiamo un cazzo a nessuno
perché sono chirchio mandiamo in
esplorazione mary jane che mi sembra il
padre che assicuri è meglio tra il padre
oneri gemba emaniamo il padre perché
sono lì cresce la barba tipo tempi il
serial quindi non va bene vai col padre
vai fuori vai fuori a prendere un po di
roba perché non abbiamo un cazzo se
riesco sopravvive che non riuscirò mai
ma se riesco non ci riesco di pietro ma
se riesco voglio le medaglie servite da
tip e nude che escono le tette fuori da
casa mia non lo stanno seriamente parte
gli scherzi ancora un cazzo per mary
jane poi darò qualcosa non siamo grandi
fan di rifugi piccoli però quando
abbiamo sentito qualcosa inizia in
quanti caso avete sentito che c'è una
cristiana so dobbiamo salvare le nostre
risorse cosa salviamo c'è solo questo
non c'è un caso il padre non tornerà mai
manco a crepare droghe prendi le droghe
no va bene non sarebbe dalla scatola di
medicina che in realtà è piena di matt
perché il padre heisenberg adesso li
dovranno per forza tabella mangiare
strano questa mi crei fa per terra
abbiamo anche un po da mangiare che non
so che sei abituato al mcdonald quindi
col cazzo conditio sta diventando prima
di merda quindi arrivano gli insetti
quindi fai come faccio io quando
incontro i ragni spruzza la merda è più
bello dovevo farlo prima ragazzi che due
persone sono più controllabilità l'altro
è tornato il padre con un fucile dove
cazzo appreso la nostra paura povera
caso è stata completamente distrutta
sopra nostro rifugio va beh non avevamo
dubbi più due di zuppa più 2 d'acqua è
più un fucile io ti adoro zio è meglio
di walter white ragazzi che già
indossato un cazzo al padre
dovrebbe mangiare o bere perché sono
crepa per terra ma io gli do un cazzo di
niente quindi l'unica roba che non l'ho
capito ragazze come contattiamo i
militari se c'è in realtà si potrebbe
vincere in questa modalità però non un
cazzo non la mappa non orario non ho
niente fosse solo una radio eh magari
guardalo appena detto lady jane ha fatte
di sandri un cazzo in faccia e poi dopo
un po ad avere da mangiare sono mi muore
per terra entro una notte ma va bè
ragazzi se vinco se vinco voglio
certamente il fi che continua a dire se
vinco che non vincerò mai nella vita
prova versi colta e naso a patata
facciamo qualcosa o that the ignorant si
svestono date guidate che stava per
finire nostro pranzo quando c'era un
tizio che era interessata dai proiettili
ma vediamoli sti cazzo di proietti
vediamo che cosa ci dà indietro spero
che ci dia qualcosa perché se me li
fotte vasta mi incazzo e botta di culo
ci ha dato una radio fantasma anche la
mappa ragazzi se la tipa torna con la
mappa godo imi che torna con vi prego vi
supplico falla tornare con a radio y vai
vai vai col a radio usiamo la sagra
radio mica non ci posso credere
preghiamo iddio che torni con la map
sipro deve tornare semi crepa sul caso
adesso deve tornare oramai più ragazzi
vi prego ecco la giornata cazzo dimmi
che non è morta ti prego dimmi che non è
morta di mika non è morta prego se si è
tornata grande ziano hai portato un pene
per anno lascia prendi lascia ha
prodotto più una maschera più un coso
fantastico il problema è che ci serve
assolutamente
la mappa spy i ragni sono ovunque non
sembrano spaventati da noi ma [ __ ]
schiacciateli sono sedici o modalità
difficile ai ragazzi non c'è aspetto che
al padre ragazzi passi la malattia
perché se no non lo mando fuori c'e
paura che mi crepa dati fa è a posto
tutto a posto dai vai vai vai così vai
così rete non è nelle condizioni non lo
mando fuori sono nelle condizioni
cos'è quando mary jane e ha trovato dei
semi nel rifugio e la morte dei semi non
state un po fortunati e l'acqua e
crescere il nostro cibo non sappiamo se
questi sono semi vegetali ma se lo sono
piantandoli potrebbe essere fantastico
devo usare una bottiglietta d'acqua per
strizzare nostro nuovo giardino si dai
proviamoci [ __ ] tanto che abbiamo
da perdere preghiamo iddio che cresca un
albero del gesù perché sono affatto
abbiamo sprecato una bottiglia per sta
roba
non vorrei di tende abbastanza vigorosa
per andare nella vai vai vai che lo
mandiamo ai che lo mandiamo lo so che in
realtà vuoi andare fuori li vedo che c'è
una bella cera per uscire vai così diamo
dell'acqua ed io prego iddio che torni
ti prego torna per favore perché se
muori abbiamo perso tutti giorno 20
ragazzi io me lo so lo so ce la posso
fare
ma come di end
mary jane ha scoperto di non avere
l'acqua ed è uscita pazza ha capito ma
c'è ancora il tipo se le sarei svignata
ma sto stronzo di merda scappato via ma
dai ma veramente ci stavo veramente
credendo ragazzi invece uno è scappata
perché pazza e l'altro è riuscito a caso
va beh riproviamoci ragazzi stavolta coi
contro maroni però perché se non altro
che bella la targa che c'è scritto sixty
seconds una comica vista nottata adesso
perché c'è uno spirito di osservazione
che fa veramente paura i carciofi e
passato un ufo a cazzo
dire ma cambia solo all'inizio cambia
tutto cioè nel senso più incasinato
anche dopo lo riesco a prendere niente
ragazzi dalla figlia è troppo pesa la
moglie dove la moglie a [ __ ] non ho
avuto un secondo di tempo neanche adesso
calmo veloce veloce veloce l'acqua
l'acqua brava forse mia moglie posso
succhiare il latte dalle sue teste non
ha niente devi prendere l'acqua per
forza zio è meglio di così non posso
fare lega impossibile la torcia cazzo e
non saprò mai l'ho presa io ce l'ho
fatta ce l'ho fatta
la faccia non ce la faccio più tengo
sofferma ho vinto perfetto non ho ben
capito che cosa è cambiato a parte il
fatto che c'era meno tempo c'era non
c'era melo tempo non so non ho capito
non ha una sega parte provvista bei
ragazzi non possiamo farcela ragazzi so
che sarà il più difficile del normale
baciava facciamo mi avete consigliato
ragazzi non so se questa cosa è vera
spero di sì che timi che il figlio
te lo mando in spedizione dovrebbe
riuscire a fare più cose degli altri non
so se è vero però per non saper né
leggere né scrivere né mangiare né bere
nel giocare a dama facciamo non
pensavamo di poter avere del cibo
semplicemente con una partita a carte
con un tizio ha matato non ci abbiamo le
carte quindi col cazzo ragazzi la gente
che mi bussagli sopra mi chiede di
giocare a carte per darmi del cibo e la
cosa più assurda che potesse esistere a
posto tutto a posto non ho dato da
mangiare a nessuno eppure tutto a posto
che strano lo sentite
no perché nessuno sta parlando su una
parola per delle ore
nessuna possiamo soltanto fissare queste
mura abbiamo bisogno di fare qualcosa
tipo accendere la radio e ascoltare
discoradio però quella è un'altra roba
che cazzo è successo a mia figlia ci ha
portato via le provviste ma abbiamo
praticamente tutto solo che mia figlia
si è trasformata in shrek nella sala
e fortuna che abbiamo ad aver portato la
radio con noi possiamo ascoltare un po
di musica da fuori perché loro stanno
continuando a mettere musica ovviamente
dopo un bombardamento atomico mettiamo
della musica tutti che vogliono mangiare
pizza burger io non do un cazzo a
nessuno neanche i piselli fagioli
scaduti comunque ragazzi è tornato il
figlio mai staccato il parrucchino un
cadavere o che cosa c'è in testa zio e
mezzo morto tra i portato qualcosa fra
attento all acquasanta come al solito
c'è andato l'acquasanta quindi più due
di acqua mary jane fame di vita di merda
ma questi devono lavare ma non hanno
l'acqua perfetto così da lavare con
l'insetticida io sai cosa ragazzi ancora
non l'ho capito cioè spruzzarsi
l'insetticida è la cosa più orribile
della storia ve lo posso garantire
e sono sopravvissuto per miracolo di
spedizione vai col padre padre il padre
è pronto ha mangiato però prima ditemi
di si perchè se no mi crepa al massimo
gli ordini amo una pizza a domicilio
chissenefrega così tutta quella roba
verde dove arriva oh mio dio ma com'e
non va bene non va bene per niente si
ragazzi non so che cosa sia roba tossica
non un cazzo per mandarla via quindi
ingoiate vela rega che vi devo dire
amico mio sento che sai da dio non hai
preso anche un'ascia e trovata una
colonia di boscaioli ma cosa mangiamo
sempre timi fuori ragazze non ho casa
aspetto sbagliato mi sa che ho fatto una
gran cagata perché timi non stava
proprio bene
ragazzi ho appena ucciso timi se così
possiamo chiamarlo poi qualcuno ha
bussato alla porta sembra un
commerciante che sembra interessata
munizioni ovviamente diamogli una dama
perché la dama è simbolo dissi di
munizioni roditori mutanti ci stanno
attaccando la madonna usa questo i
ragazzi non vorrei dire ma sono al
giorno 18 in modalità difficile mi è
solo morto un figlio per ora niente di
che è arrivato l'esercito perfetto
l'importante è avere una mappa con sé
per di lì dove sia un problema è che non
so la mappa porca [ __ ] ragazzi sto
per mandare dolores fuori quindi
tenetevi pronti perchè sarà una cosa
tragica non so cosa potrà mai trovare
quella donna che potrebbe sorprendere di
più di un bussare alla c'è qualcuno che
sta bussando dovremo rischiare
potrebbe essere una buona idea potremmo
aprire la porta vabbè dai aprile morchio
appuntano quanto a merda son dato ma
veramente l'arci andato il libro di boy
scout ma si sono fottuti mia figlia
[Musica]
inizia ce l'avevo le ministre non mi
ricordo anche lascia meraviglioso sono
fottuti mia figlia però va beh cosa
cazzo succede ci hanno portato
dell'acqua ci hanno portato via del cibo
mia moglie è morta o capitolo è la
modalità difficile aragami sono pazzi ha
veramente di passo c'è solo il tizio col
calzino complimenti per il calzino zio
lasciamo perdere l'acqua il problema è
il cibo in chan foto tutto cibo non c'è
più nessuno niente vr esistere finché
non arrivano la minchia altro mia moglie
è molto molto gnocca complimenti magra
come se potresti fare la modella zia il
problema è che sei brutta come la fame
però va bene è morto adesso fa vissuto
senza mangiare a chi ha bisogno ma chi
ne ha bisogno sono cose fittizie quindi
ragazzi concluso che l'episodio non c'è
più la pizza tra l'altro non lo voglio
sapere va bene così ragazzi è stato
alquanto strano ci ho creduto fino alla
fine non ci siamo riusciti notte sega
quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
concludo episodio e cosa sento ragazzi
se video è piaciuto lasciato vento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e
comune di video trovata nelle scrizioni
sono se avessi discrete ci vediamo al
prossimo video bella ragazza